Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, for sure.
So yeah, I guess I just thought we could have a chat.
I think I have some questions for you and then you might have some questions for me.
We don't really have a lot of structure to this, but cool.
So I guess the first thing I was curious about is you are relatively new to flying and how
did you get here?
Well let's see, I started in the ICU in 2016 and there was a few years of drowning in the
education and all the things that we do in the ICU.
As I got more, I think a theme I was thinking of before I came over, it was the concept
of fake it till you make it.
That point it seemed like I was pretty confident in what I was doing and even though internally
like I didn't feel that way, I think one of my co-workers at the time was like, yeah,
I have been flying for a couple of years, you should start flying.
And then it was like, oh, you think I'm ready for that?
And then she was like, yeah, you should apply, here's the application.
So I started flying for a fix me company and it was all PRN at the time, which was kind
of cool for me because I was working full time in the ICU and then I would have my extra
days of being on call.
Whether we did something or not, you get paid while you're home, so that was pretty sweet.
I always knew that I wanted to go into flight.
When I got into nursing school, it was like, okay, eventually I'm going to do flight.
So I worked there for like four years or so before I came to Air Mythids.
The last year, it's completely different from what I was doing before in a good way,
I think.
But yeah, to answer your question more shortly, I always knew I wanted to fly.
That's kind of always been a goal of mine.
And the hospital you're working at, you were in an ICU and as a trauma surgical ICU, right
on.
Yeah, so yeah, you know what that's like.
For sure.
And we would do everything.
Yeah, and then some background for everyone, like Morgan and I work together in the ICU
and now we work at the same base for Care Flight here in Santa Fe.
Or up there in Santa Fe, elsewhere in Albuquerque.
So how has it been like the transition from like bedside nursing into like fixed-wing
flight and then into rotors?
Because I think that's a question that like a lot of people have when they're considering
whether they want to get into this whole scene in general.
Yeah, I think it was pretty similar to starting out in a sub-acute floor and going to an ICU,
like a busy ICU where you have these expectations and there's just things that you're expected
to know and do in the ICU.
Kind of similar to me in that sense going from fixed-wing to rotor.
It was like, okay, now you've learned some things here, apply that and then add on top
of all of the other aeromedical stuff, aeronautical stuff, flight physiology and logistics that
you just don't see in an ICU or in a hospital or a space.
The pre-hospital stuff is, it was quite overwhelming for me at first.
Yeah.
It's also like the different patient populations.
In the nursing side, we tend to be pigeonholed into one specific patient set.
In our ICU, we never see kids.
We rarely see kids.
Right.
Yeah.
Definitely not babies.
Or pregnant women.
Yeah, totally.
I remember like a few times where you get a younger kid that comes into the ICU or pregnant
woman or post hemorrhage or whatever.
It's like, well, what do you mean?
I don't know what I'm doing here.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I think that aspect has been challenging for sure in a rotor setting.
You're still getting fed information with a fire hose.
It's only been a little over a year for me in that arena, so it still feels pretty.
It can feel overwhelming sometimes.
Currently I just got through a bunch of quarterly innovations and quarterly stuff that we have
to do.
It's like stressing to get that done before the 20th while studying for my CFRN.
When you test?
Next month.
Nice.
Yeah.
I'm not looking forward to it.
Yes, it's a necessary evil in the process.
It's weird to do a certification that your job requires you to have.
There's this added pressure of like, yeah, if I fail again, then I lose my job?
That sucks.
Yeah, because I guess normally you would get the certification first, so it's behind
you before you transition into the job.
Interesting.
Did you have your CFRN before you started flying?
I did.
Well, I kind of went about it in a different way because I flew as a medic first.
I had my FPC already before I got my nursing degree.
At the time we had a different transition process for medics to become nurses.
I was a nurse and was working in both the ER and ICU, but I was still getting paid in
flight as a medic.
In protest, I just took all my advanced certs and was like, you guys should pay me more.
They were like, no.
I was like, cool, I'm going to leave.
Then let me come back eventually.
That's why I did it that way.
I thought maybe I could shift the seas of the giant company if I like, straw-garb them
in with all my pieces of paper.
They're very sad in their ways.
Yeah, totally.
That's okay.
They let me come back eventually, so it's fine.
I think in that, just hearing your story about it, it seems compared to where I'm at right
now mentally, I'm freaking out about this certification.
I failed once already.
I'm re-studying, doing it again, and going to retest.
You had your FPC.
You just went to nurses who were like, well, I'm just going to take this test now.
Yeah, it's safe stuff.
I think I'm also pretty lucky in that that I've always done pretty well at taking tests.
I recognize that is not the case for a lot of people.
Sure.
I think BPA had an unfair advantage in that.
Yeah, I mean, it is what it is, right?
Yeah, totally.
Everybody has their own thing.
I've always struggled taking tests.
It's just who I am.
You'll figure it out.
I'm not worried.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Really.
Then another question I had for you is, you did all of your nursing time in the...
inpatient side.
How do you think about, like in hindsight, do you think there's value in getting ER experience
as well?
Most people come to flight either with ER experience or ICU experience.
Occasionally, we see people have both, but normally, most nurses follow one track or
the other.
What are your thoughts on that?
I think it would depend on where you're at.
I've talked to a few people recently that work full time in the ER and don't really
have a lot of experience with titrating drips or using multiple drips to get a certain effect
or a certain outcome.
I think it would be pretty helpful to have more experience with pediatrics because that's
always a source of contention with people in general.
I think the universal thought is, peeds are just challenging in general.
Yeah, kids are scary.
Yeah.
Sure.
I personally, had I thought about that ahead of time, I probably would have tried to do
some more time in pediatrics, not so much in like NICU specific or working in the ER
in the hopes that I would get some peeds here and there, but actually, go work in the PICU.
Go work in the Peds ED.
That I think would be beneficial.
Yeah, especially at a hospital like UNM where they have a dedicated PDR, so it's an available
option.
The flip side of that though, I think is, does it really matter?
No.
For sure.
Yeah, that's one thing.
I don't know if we ever had this conversation when you were looking to come fly.
All you have to do is I'm oversimplifying here, but to get into a flight program is
you have to demonstrate that you're not an asshole and that you're trainable.
Then you get along with people and they will teach you the things that you don't know yet.
But expecting people to know how to operate in an aircraft when they've never done it
is unfair.
Expecting someone to know how to take care of a sick OB patient or a kid when they've
never done it, that's unrealistic.
Also, even when you train, I think we're going to get to this, but I got lucky I think in
that I had a lot of time to train in a rotor during my orientation.
People don't get that at all.
They're training on fixed wing and then they're coming to a rotor base and they're like,
well, I've never even flown in a helicopter.
How do you expect me to work now?
Yeah, that's how it was for me because when I started here, we didn't have any, we only
had A-stars in the state.
All of my orientation was a fixed wing.
Your first rotor shift is the first time you're putting on your helmet, NVGs and going to
a scene flight.
I was lucky that I had some background in the EMS side, but I can't imagine coming into
that scene, not having done that, trying to manage your first scene without ...
I think that's what I came to realize is the more challenging part of Air Medical is the
stuff that you just have no exposure to.
When I went on my first scene call, luckily I was with somebody that knew what they were
doing because I was just like this lost puppy wandering around like, yeah, I can carry that.
I can do that.
We're like, sure, sure, whatever.
Totally.
Just like running around, not really being efficient in any way.
Yeah.
I think it's also worth remembering that that's fine.
I think we tend to have this perception, we as ground EMS people and nurse in the hospital,
that the flight crew is like ...
I know exactly what they're doing.
Yeah, they're on it all the time.
Yeah.
They just wear cool pajamas.
That's it.
Yeah.
It has been an interesting experience to see that firsthand too.
I walk into a room and I'm like, shitting my pants about what we're about to do and
what's going to happen.
Everybody's looking at you like, okay, what's next?
I'm like, I don't know.
Yeah.
Sometimes you just got to do something or convince everyone else to do nothing.
Just like make a decision one way or the other.
You don't necessarily have to do stuff, but voice a decision and it's probably going to
be fine.
Then going back to this fake it till you make it concept.
I think it's very useful and it can be pretty prevalent in critical care space in general.
It totally helped me get from where I was to where I am.
In the process, I still struggle with imposter syndrome.
There's a lot that I know and there's a whole lot that I don't know.
Yeah.
Then being able to recognize that and have the humility to be like, well, let's confer
with someone else.
Let's get some help from someone else or figure that out.
I think is still a pretty key attribute to have.
Yeah.
I think that's normal.
I think if you ever get to a situation where you never have any doubt about what you're
doing, probably just not looking hard enough for sure.
I think that is a healthy response because you don't want to be overconfident in what
you're doing.
Even for me, I've been flying for a long time now.
I started flying in 2013 and I forgot the blood at the base the other day going on a
seed flight.
It's like, yeah, it happens.
You make mistakes and it's part of the game.
Yeah.
But then owning it.
Totally.
The owning it is the.
For sure.
Yeah.
We had to like, yeah, we figured it out.
It was fine.
Yeah.
Pinching.
It's like, I've been out blood for a long time.
Yeah.
But does make you feel really silly and that's okay.
That's part of it.
Yeah.
If everything was easy, the appeal of the job would be different.
I think my clinical director knows me by name and when I'm on shift, usually expects a call
on early morning or after shift to have some sort of conversation or explanation of something
I did different or wrong or whatever.
Yeah.
And that's totally fine.
Not that I'm like a terrible clinician, which is what it kind of making myself up to be.
But they, if you were terrible, you probably wouldn't still be worth a year.
So yeah.
So yeah, I think, I think it's natural to get into the flight world with the skills you
have and then develop as you go.
For sure.
Yeah.
It totally makes sense.
So having made it through this, I guess you could call it like a prolonged transition
period from like bedside nursing into flight, you've kind of started a project to help other
people navigate this transition as well.
You want to talk about that a bit?
Yeah.
So I started a school group.
Are you familiar with school?
Only through your project.
So it's a pretty cool application.
I was developed by some guys that wanted to combine creating a community with monetizing
it somehow.
And so they've done all the back end work on the pages and the applications that you
can set up, setting up links and all of that.
And so it was pretty easy to set up.
But the overall goal really for me was coming out of working in the ICU.
You work with a set of people pretty much consistently.
You're training people daily, educating yourself and educating them.
I always felt like the best way for me to learn things is to try and learn it and then
teach it to someone else.
And I think UNM is pretty pro that just being like the teaching hospital that it is.
You're expected to train people right off orientation essentially.
And so then not having that kind of community or space where I'm teaching someone else something.
And also, I mean, the guys at the base, you guys are all really knowledgeable.
And so it's really been cool to learn from you guys about it.
But also then have a space where people can come talk about their struggles, talk about
cases that were challenging.
Because sometimes you go through a situation and then you come out the other side like
what really happened there?
I'm not really sure how we got from where we were to where we went and what we did in
between.
So to bring those cases, bring those challenging situations or scenarios and get a different
perspective because that has always really helped me.
So that's really been the goal for me to create a space that people can do that in.
And it's been pretty cool.
There's some new people that I think are hopefully getting some benefit out of the group.
There's a lot of experience.
You're in there.
You've got a ton of experience.
Derek Grassley, he's been there for a while and he's always posting new things.
Things that I didn't really ever think to do.
So being able to pool that kind of knowledge and make it a safe space to share what we're
dealing with.
For sure.
That's been the goal for it.
And particularly with our program, it's a pretty distinct difference between clinician
and educator.
There are some exceptions there, but for the most part, we tend to separate that.
Which is very different from how it's done at the hospital we came from.
But yeah, that was kind of a similar motivation for me starting this whole project was having
a platform to iron out those details about complicated things or trying to explain something
that you think you know and then you go to write it down or make a video on it and you're
like, wait a second.
This is not coming out how I thought it would.
Maybe I don't know this as well as I did or as I thought I did.
So yeah, that's cool.
Well, and that's a cool, I think it takes humility and awareness, right?
To look at something and be like, oh yeah, I know this.
And then start to talk about it.
You're like, wait a second.
I don't think this is actually right.
Totally.
But to have then a sounding board, like someone to talk to, some group of people to bring
that to and be like, does anybody else have any other experience with this?
That's always been a big proponent or I've been a big proponent for that.
But also then taking that information and like, oh yeah, okay.
So I can learn something from it.
Yeah, yeah, that's cool.
And you also have like, I guess you call it a social media presence that accompanies
that.
So yeah, with the, really the school group is the platform that I'm sending people to
through the Instagram page.
And the Instagram page is more of like the marketing side of it, I would say.
And so I've been learning how to make reels and kind of try and make them interesting,
catch people's attention.
And then they start to, like hopefully then they're scrolling through the comments or
the commentary and getting the link to the school group.
Yeah.
I think for my project, it's been a little different, but I definitely have learned how
to do a lot of things on like the tech side that I wouldn't have ever learned before.
Like I mean the podcast thing, like managing RSS feed, like editing videos and like making
graphics on the computer.
It's been kind of cool.
There's nothing else just for like developing that skillset.
Yeah.
Which is funny now because like, you know, like some people, they can do the things that
take me like hours to do and they just like happened so fast because they grew up doing
that.
Yeah.
Makes me feel like a little bit old.
But yeah, it's been cool to learn.
Yeah.
No, I feel the same.
I'm getting better at it now, but like when I first started it, it would take me like
an hour or something to like make one real.
Totally.
And yeah, so now it's getting faster.
Yeah.
After you start, I'm starting to like struggle with ideas like, oh, what am I going to talk
about now?
Yeah.
And that's definitely like something very different between like how you do your social
media stuff and I do because you've kind of like set a goal to like post things every
day where I post like sometimes like I have time in a week and I post a couple of times
and sometimes it's like months between things.
Yeah.
It's like radio sounds for a while.
But yeah, I've never felt that pressure to like come up with ideas because I just have
like a continual backlog on my phone.
Like, okay, someday when I have time, I'll do these things.
Nice.
But yeah, that's interesting.
Yeah.
And the research and stuff that I've put into learning how to be a better social media,
you know, influencer or video maker or whatever, you know, the algorithm has its own brain
and you really have to do things in a certain way to make the algorithm push your stuff
out.
Interesting.
Because otherwise, you can you just posting when you want to and not that that's bad.
Like that's yeah, it was like a different motivation for sure.
Right.
But I have found like, this is the third social media page that I've started.
And like my other one died because I wasn't posting enough.
And so there's like, you know, there's like 10 followers and it doesn't ever grow.
Somehow, you know, in then you start to get into this, like, okay, at what point do I
do I take quality over quantity for sure, because I'm just trying to post three reels
a day that can be challenging in itself to have enough stuff to enough media to post
and things to talk about.
But but yeah, at some point, I think I'm going to have to switch more to like a person or
an in person presence for sure and then have more quality stuff than than just quality.
Yeah.
And I found like, from my stuff, a lot of the value that I get back out of it is just
in like messages and comments on stuff like the dialogue that comes from whatever you're
doing to get people's attention.
Yeah.
Like maybe someone doesn't actually like care to read the whole thing you posted, but they
like the idea or they like picked out a picture that they recognize or something like that.
And they like reach out about it.
Yeah.
So I think that's pretty cool.
No, and I do like the like I made a real it's been a few weeks now.
And in the moment, it was just something to get out there.
Like it's literally they has no value to me whatsoever.
Like it's literally me like turning the monitor on and off.
And then I said something like I because I haven't before flight, I never used the Zoll
monitor.
And I was like, sometimes I miss the Philips bedside monitor because you can take a blood
pressure and is exactly what you think it's going to be.
You know that that's the correct value.
You know, in a helicopter, it's not that way sometimes.
And so many people have taught have been talking about that that one year, it's got
like 50,000 views and they're sharing it.
Oh, wow.
This holds no clinical values at all.
Like huh, it's kind of interesting what whether it's the algorithm or whether it's like people,
I don't know.
But huh.
Yeah, I had a video that I made like a couple years back and it was just like, you know,
there's like different like one person techniques you can do for a bougie where you like flip
it around and like, um, poke it through the eyelet.
Yeah, like I did a video and I posted on Instagram and got like, I don't know, like handful of
views couple.
I don't know.
I was like viewed like a couple thousand times.
But a few months ago, somebody sent me my video and someone it was like, this like metal
music track over top of it.
And I had like hundreds of thousands of views on TikTok.
And I was like, what the fuck?
How does that happen?
Yeah, I mean, it's I think it's partly the algorithm.
I think it's partly, you know, what, what people are sharing at the time.
Yeah, for sure.
But but yeah, it's it's been a fun.
It's been a fun project and a fun thing to learn about kind of on the side.
Yeah.
I'm not sure what the sound is there.
What is the instruction?
Yeah, what's the the hope with it?
You mentioned that you maybe have to like change your strategy or eventually like what
do you do you see it going?
Yeah, I mean, right now I think it's kind of in its infancy, trying to just create followers
and learn kind of where I'm going with it.
Most of my stuff that I put out right now is kind of on, you know, like the mental aspect
of nursing and flight, just because that's where I'm at, I think.
So I think it will change as I as I change.
You mean like, just working in the setting in general, like working in health care?
And also, like, you know, we have a challenging job, like we do a lot of things.
I'm made aware most of the days that I'm home that not a lot of people can do the job we
do.
My wife hates hearing about the stories that I have.
And she like doesn't want to listen to me, doesn't want to like have a conversation about
them.
And like when I go out and people ask what I do and I say I'm a flight nurse and they're
like, oh my God, like how do you do that?
So anyway, the point I think is that we have a challenging job and it is good to recognize
that.
For sure.
Because it's easy to get burnt out.
I mean, the burnout rate for clinicians is something like 65%.
We're always in a nursing shortage.
We're always in a provider shortage.
There's more people leaving health care than there are coming in.
And so I think it's cool and useful to build awareness for and also share some of the tips
and tricks and things that I've learned along the way that hopefully benefit other people.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, and I think some of that does like crossover to the general population, but definitely
it's like more apparent for folks in our field, like just the cumulative exposure to like
shitty fucked up things is definitely above average.
Yeah.
In the ICU too versus in critical care, it's one of the highest assault areas in the world,
in the country, probably in the world.
I don't know that statistic, but in the country for sure.
And yeah, it's shitty and we still choose to do it anyway.
So yeah.
Moving on to something less sad.
Transitioning into flight, what is your favorite part about working in flight?
Like the lifestyle that affords you?
Well, I mean the days off for sure are awesome.
I don't think I know of anywhere that you can work two days a week.
Yeah, it's pretty rad.
So that's pretty sweet.
And sorry, what was the question where?
Like what do you like?
My favorite thing?
Transition to flight.
It's very distracting.
It is very distracting.
I have really enjoyed the scene call and like getting to fly around in helicopters
just like super rad.
It's super fun.
But then like, you know, like one of my favorite things about working in the ICU was when I
would recover an open heart patient and it would just be me in a room with this critically
ill patient managing all the drips, managing all the chest tubes and outputs and, you know,
finding things that could go wrong and preventing them from happening along the same lines in
flight.
You're doing the same thing except with way less information.
Totally.
Like you show up to a place and you have no idea what this person's background is, what
they do on their free time and you have to figure out how to get them from point A to
point B as stable as possible and work with another human being to do that.
And there's just a lot of different variables that go into that.
But like that part has been really challenging and enjoying that challenge has been cool
for me to see in myself.
You know, you like learn this other person's way of communicating and, you know, thought
process and you can then start to like, you know, just start doing things and they're
right there backing you up or doing the same thing on their end or whatever.
It's like this weird little, I don't know, microcosm of like things that you're all just
like compiling together to like for one immediate goal.
Yeah.
And on a time crunch.
Yeah, that's cool.
I particularly like that aspect of it, but also it sticks up on you.
You know, like most of the flights we do are pretty routine.
All of a sudden you're like sleeping in your cozy bed at two o'clock in the morning and
then you get woken up and you're expected to perform in coordination with your other
with your partner clinician at like a very high level.
Like I like that challenge of going from just like baseline chilling the base or sleeping
like having to be on it right away.
I think that's really cool.
That's something we don't get in the hospital side so much.
Like we get very, very sick patients that are in our ICU.
But you have time, you know, you can prep, you can look through the chart, like you can
figure out the story before you get all your shit set up.
So you're like ready to go.
You're like, I got this.
I know ahead of time before they get here that I got it.
You don't have time to do that in flight, which is cool, but you still have to do it.
Yeah.
I think that's really neat.
The other thing that I think has been particularly interesting for me is like I'm a planner.
Like I like to plan things out.
I like to know ahead of time.
So like, you know, I definitely have that ICU brain where I'm like, all right, I can prep
for all these things.
But not having that information ahead of time has forced me to like think about things
that could go wrong.
And then, okay, then what things am I going to need in a pinch?
And so that has been really interesting and challenging for me to adapt to.
But still kind of along the same lines.
Yeah.
Well, I think that's all the questions I had.
Okay.
For you.
Yeah.
I wanted to ask about, so you have been flying, you said for since 2013.
But not consistently the whole time.
I'd like come and gone a couple of times, but like the majority of the last like 11
or 12 years.
Yeah.
So you have, you've been able to kind of do a lot of different things within the same
kind of context of being a medic, being a nurse, being in critical care.
And so I was curious about how you got into DMAT and you know what that is.
Yeah.
So the DMAT is a disaster medical assistance team.
So basically the federal government has a number of teams that respond in a medical
capacity to disasters, mostly here in the US, but every once in a blue moon, a team
will get sent overseas.
And yeah, I first learned about the whole DMAT program.
I took a class years ago when I first moved out to New Mexico.
So it's like over 10 years ago, I took a class up in Seattle with this group called
Remote Medical International.
They used to do this class that was called remote medicine for the advanced provider.
So it's for like medics, nurses, mid-levels, physicians to like kind of teach you how to
operate as a, like an expedition lead in an outdoor setting.
And one of the guys who was in my class, he was a medic with...
So is that kind of similar to search and rescue?
A little bit different in that this particular class was more for like, let's say you're
going on like a back country trip or you're hired as a medical provider for an expedition,
like how to plan for that in general, like which equipment to bring from the front country
to the back country, how to improvise the things that you ought to be improvising, how
to like know when like you should just take the piece of equipment and not improvise,
how to decide which medications to take, all of that.
So more like on the planning and logistics side of that versus like search and rescue
where like someone's lost and like, kind of like in our situation where you just like
go on a call out basis to fight them.
But anyways, one of the medics in that class, he was a King County Medic 1 paramedic and
he was on the Washington State DMAT team and he mentioned it to me.
So at the time I reached out to try to like find something about our DMAT here in New
Mexico because I, you know, through searching on the Googles, I found out that we had a
team.
It turns out that Kevin Knapp, who was also a medic at our base in Santa Fe is the assistant
team commander for New Mexico DMAT.
So I had a phone call with him like almost a decade ago and he was like, yeah, you should
put in for our team whenever we like open hiring again.
The time is like pretty convoluted for like how to get in on the team.
So it was like years later that I finally got assigned to the DMAT program in general.
At that time I was on contract in Seattle, like doing a travel nursing contract.
So I got assigned to like the Washington State team.
And then when I finally finished my orientation, I was on a contract in Reno.
So they put me, they moved me to the California team.
And then when I moved back to New Mexico a few years ago, I finally made it to New Mexico
1 DMAT.
Wow.
So it was a little bit of a convoluted process.
I think now.
It's been a long process.
Yeah.
Now it's a little more streamlined, although there are some complications with like, yeah,
like federal hiring at the moment.
But it's a pretty cool program in that we basically take call.
Our team is on call for two or three months every year.
And then when we're on call, if we get deployed, we just like pack up as a team and hop on
a plane and go to wherever this disaster happens to be.
So so far I've been out twice.
One of them, I went to American Samoa a couple of years back for like a COVID response.
And then most recently I was in North Carolina for Hurricane Helene this best fall.
So that is completely unrelated to your trips to Ukraine and Gaza?
Unrelated.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the DMAT stuff is like here through a federal program.
So it's like a, it's like a normal job in that, like when I get deployed, I get paid
for it.
But I've been interested in that general like disaster and humanitarian response field for
a long time.
And through that interest is how I ended up both in Gaza and the couple of trips I've
been over to Ukraine with.
When I was younger, before I got really like vested in the healthcare space, like I would
occasionally like travel and like do some volunteer work with like different like humanitarian
projects.
I think like the first time I left the country when I was a kid, I went to maybe in like
seventh grade, I went to Guatemala with like a church project that was basically someone
years ago, I had like gone to this little village and they put a well at the top of
this mountain.
And every summer they would go back and like run the piping from the well to another village
to like provide water to people.
And my brother had gone the year before me, he was a couple of years older than me and
he had a great time and he convinced me to go with him.
So we like sold donuts at church on Sundays for like six months, like raise money so we
could like go on the strip with the church group.
But that kind of like sparked an interest in like doing that kind of thing, like both
like traveling and getting like forward aid.
Yeah, like getting out of the country, like putting yourself in a situation where like
you have no idea what's going on.
And also like finding a way to like give back.
And then like as I got older and like was a medic and a nurse, like I eventually realized
that I could do both.
Like I could do that kind of like international travel and help and also like work in my field.
So I've done a lot of different projects over the years.
Yeah, like working in healthcare overseas.
And it's kind of like by chance it kind of evolved into like more like high risk in like
conflict stuff.
That wasn't really by design.
It just sort of like happened that I was like working for a nonprofit that like they also
worked in that space and they kind of included me in some of their projects that kind of
pushed me in that direction.
Cool.
Yeah.
So back up a second.
So it's unrelated, but kind of related to your trips to Ukraine and Gaza.
How did you so these are just like you found people along your travels or knowing people
within DMAT that kind of do this other.
Yeah, not necessarily within DMAT, but like in that, like the community of like medical
providers who like work overseas is like fairly small and it's kind of segmented.
There's like a lot of folks who like work in disaster response.
There's another like group of folks who work in the humanitarian response.
And then there's like a smaller group over here that works like in like the more high
risk settings.
The overlap between them like it kind of varies.
You know, there's some people who like straddle two or three of those, but I've been kind
of like exploring opportunities in like all of those spaces for a while.
So it's kind of, I guess at this point, like I have a fairly well established network so
that when something comes up, like I often like am in the loop on like who is putting
a roster together to get a team there and what they're doing.
So yeah, it took me a long time to like get into that field.
Like you, like for people who are like interested in like pursuing that type of work, a lot
of like stuff, a lot of opportunities are available where you kind of like pay to volunteer,
like you pay your own way to get that experience.
But then once you have done that a couple times, then you like know people in the field
and they reach out to you and then then like the next step would be to like find projects
that are funded where you can actually get your travel paid for or stipend or maybe even
like make some money off of it.
That kind of goes back to like what we were talking about getting into flight, right?
You have to still be like a cool person, like you have to work well with other people.
You have to know your shit.
Yeah, for sure.
Especially for like more committing things, things that are like maybe considered to be
a little more dangerous.
Like you don't really know like how you're going to do in that setting until you're there.
But you sort of have to like prove to someone that like you're at least competent in like
the medical side that you're doing and then you like you get along with people and then
you're like open to things being a little like unknown.
Yeah.
And then you like try something a little more challenging.
That goes well.
Yeah, you just kind of like keep going.
Yeah.
No, I think that's so cool.
If I, you know, were 10 years younger and didn't have as many responsibilities as I
do, I would totally jump on that.
But I wanted to, I wanted to kind of, and this is cool segue, but like I wanted to get
into more of what you have experienced overseas with, you know, your trips to Gaza and Ukraine
kind of, and specifically in how your experiences as a flight nurse and being a medic have contributed
to your success over there with, you know, whatever clinical aspects came up.
Yeah.
So the first time I went over to Ukraine was like right after the initial full scale invasion.
And there was a nonprofit that I was working with at the time.
I wasn't working full time for them, but I had done some work with them before.
So they brought me on to go over to Ukraine with them.
And we got tasked as part of this like working group to help set up a medevac program to
like move patients.
Initially it was like from Western Ukraine, like far away from the front from Western
Ukraine across the border into Poland.
And then we coordinated with air medical assets, like in Europe to like fly them to other places
to get their like reconstructive surgery done.
And then eventually that project kind of moved further East to where now they're rendezvousing
with like ambulances coming from the frontline to pick up patients or picking up patients
and like smaller facilities closer to the frontline and moving them back to hospitals
in Ukraine.
And then other people are taking them like further West.
So my, I guess to answer your question, I guess my skillset initially was more like
just like knowing how the system works.
Yeah.
And kind of like working there like in more of a coordination role to get this like project
started.
And then there was like a little bit of gap from the first time I went over to, I went
over again last summer because I was doing like clinicals for MP school.
So I kind of like put all my travel on hold for a bit.
But when I've been back both last summer and then over the holidays recently, I was
working just as a medic in that program.
So just transporting patients.
So last summer I was there with a another group called artisans rescue and they just
do like critical care ambulance transfers.
So we're like picking up patients from hospitals, not like super close to the frontline, but
in that direction and bringing them back to like a big city where it's a little safer
where they can like get their recovery from surgery secured on a neapro D in IPR.
Oh yeah, you pro.
And then this last time I went back was with a group called caddis.
They're a group out of Berlin, another nonprofit, and they were working kind of the same system,
but they also work a little further east, like closer to the frontline.
So they have bases.
Yeah, like one up in sumi, which is up north and the one is still the answer, which is
like further east.
And we would pick up patients like a little bit further than bring them back either to
rendezvous with crews to take them back to neapro or to take them all the way back to
neapro.
And in both of those situations, we were doing basically the same stuff we do here on the
helicopter just in ambulance.
So we have like, we use the same vents, we have like IV pumps, we have like, same like
similar like pharmacologic capabilities.
It's just our patients are all almost all trauma.
So it's like slightly different patient set, whereas like here is mostly medical.
Yeah.
And then this next time I go back in a couple weeks and I'll be working again with a different
group.
But I'll be in a stabilization point or a stab point as they call it, which is basically
like an ER kind of in a like a safe space removed from the frontline where people are
coming to you.
Yeah, so they're generally transported to the stabilization point via like a military
evac like a Casa vac situation.
So they bring it to us will stabilize them.
If there's surgeons there who can like do initial like damage control surgery, like
airway management, chest tube type stuff, stop the bleed, then we will put them on ambulances
to do the next leg of things.
Cool.
Yeah.
Are those facilities managed by local agencies or are they, is there a lot of, are you seeing
a lot of US soldiers and aid and medical personnel there?
It's mostly, most of the healthcare facilities themselves are all Ukrainian.
Some of the stabilization points are staffed by international NGOs, NGOs, non-governmental
organizations.
The ones that they're getting all their funding cut from?
The ones from the US.
That's a little bit, yeah.
The US ones, but to be fair, like most in that space, most of those facilities, most
of those stabilization points don't get any kind of like funding from programs like USAID
or anything like that because they are affiliated directly with military units.
In that humanitarian space, there are like some overarching principles of humanitarian
aid and one of them is that you have to be impartial.
You kind of like separate yourself from funding sources if you are tied to any kind of like
combat unit.
Most of those organizations that work in that space in particular, they don't get any like
funding other than private donations.
Interesting.
Other groups that work like further away, some of them do get funding whether like through
the WHO or through like the country where their organization is based.
Wow, that's really cool, man.
That's, I've always, over the last whatever, it's been like year, year and a half, two
years since I've known you.
I've always been interested in hearing your, you're taking your stories from those trips
that you do and it's very admirable but also like, you know, we talked about a little bit
about getting outside your comfort zone.
That's just got to be some of the more stressful situations, not being able to speak the language
unless you are fluent in Ukrainian.
I am not.
I know you speak Spanish pretty well but so yeah, I mean, how do you feel like you deal
with that being able to do that job that you're familiar with that you've been doing for some
amount of years in an environment that is completely foreign and you don't speak the
language?
I think initially it was an unknown.
When I first got into doing medical stuff internationally or even just traveling internationally,
I always got a little bit nervous and then you realize, okay, even if I don't speak the
language, I can get around.
I can feed myself and find some more safe to sleep, right?
And then next step is can you do your job in another setting and then you figure out
that okay, it's uncomfortable but I can do this.
Then you add in a safety factor, can I still do this if it's dangerous?
And then if I'm responsible for other people in the setting and then I just stepwise, I've
discovered that I don't suck at it.
I'm okay in those settings.
I think about this for myself a lot, right?
And it's putting yourself in a situation where you're uncomfortable and seeing how you do.
Or do you find it as like, okay, I'm going to try and know as much as I can about this
particular place, this thing that I'm doing and try and buff up my knowledge about that
and try and make myself as comfortable as possible?
Yeah, I think there's a little bit of both.
Yeah, I'm trying to think of a good example.
I definitely think there's part of me that is down to try something more challenging.
When the war in Gaza kicked off and there was options to go over, I was like, yeah,
I'm going to go, but I wasn't like, I'm going to go and thrive.
I'm ready for this.
Yeah, I wasn't like, I'm going to go and thrive in the setting.
But I was like, I'm going to go because it presents a challenge.
I am curious to know how I do in that setting.
So where do you think, I'm just curious because a lot of the stuff that I post about is about
mental fortitude and mental toughness.
Where do you think that comes from for you?
I think part of it is like, I mean, inherent seemed like a little bit of a cop out, but
some people are comfortable, like being uncomfortable and some people aren't.
And I've always like, I think I've always just had that.
I don't know if that was necessarily something that I intentionally cultivated.
But on the preparation side, like you were asking about, I do a lot of things to make
that easier.
Like I have pretty regimented routine, whether I'm here or overseas, that helps me stay
calm and keep it under control.
Just accepting that there's going to be a lot of unknown and for this to go with the
flow.
I think it's fair, I think sometimes it's easier being gone than it is being here.
There's a lot of things we have to do here.
But there's been times overseas where you don't have any say, yeah, you don't get to
choose what you do, which makes it easier.
Easier in the sense that you can just do the thing.
Totally.
Rather than needing approval.
Or you don't have to put any thought into it.
You might appreciate this.
I have a little heart rate monitor, like a polar H10, whatever.
And I like every morning put it on and sit for five minutes and get my heart rate variability
and it gives me a readiness score for the day.
So I'm like, yeah, I'm like an eight or nine, I'm ready to go.
I didn't sleep well because before night I'm like a three or four.
But I've been tracking this data for a very long time.
Maybe not a very long time, but for me it feels like a long time, like three or four
years now I have a heart rate variability and a baseline heart rate for almost every
morning of my life.
And the highest numbers I've ever seen was when I was over in Gaza.
And I think part of that is I didn't have any say in what we were doing.
I could wake up, eat, go to work, come home and sleep.
And yeah, I didn't have to worry about, there's no money to be spent.
I didn't have to worry about going to work, running late, buying things, finances.
I didn't even have a lot of the time that I didn't have access to communications back
home.
It took a lot of that stuff away that we tend to stress about here.
That's really interesting actually.
I find that very interesting because in our culture, in our society, we're inundated with
stimulus.
Yeah.
And we think it's normal.
And we think it's normal, right?
We don't even notice it.
But also my lack of understanding of what it's like to be over in Gaza.
I've never been there.
No idea.
But in our society, it's like what's on the news.
And it occurs to me as like a war zone, right?
There's just shit happening all the time.
Gunfire, bombs, people dying.
It occurs to me from this outside perspective as like a really stressful over stimulating
environment.
But also without all of the things like the traffic or like phone calls or whatever things
we're inundated with here.
So it's really, I find that very fascinating.
Yeah.
And I think it is a little more nuanced than that.
It is loud.
It's never quiet there.
And the time when I was there, it was like things were blowing up all the time.
But it's different for or it was different.
It's probably still is different for like an international team there that the like
calling the combatant forces like they are aware of our location versus like someone
who lives there like a Palestinian who lives there who like doesn't have that security
protection.
So even though it is like arguably like loud and stressful and dangerous.
We did the things we could to like assure our safety and like after that like everything
was out of my control.
So like there was no utility in thinking on it more.
Yeah.
It's crazy, man.
That's cool though.
Yeah.
I think I've been like using this like analogy since I've like come back from Ukraine the
last time that like to try and like explain like how I ended up doing this kind of thing.
I think like describing as like a Venn diagram like when there's something that happens in
the world like something like a conflict or disaster.
There's like a lot of people who want to go like a lot of people want to help.
But a very small group of that chunk like have a skill set and demeanor and like the
like stability back home to actually go and like make it work.
And there are a lot of people that do have the capability to go like do something useful
but they don't want to go where they're not comfortable with the risk.
And like the overlap between them is like maybe quite small and kind of just by chance
like discover that like I fit in that like the little overlap in that Venn diagram.
And like another factor that like really helps is that like both jobs back here in the US
have been amazingly flexible with me.
Like one thing that holds up a lot of people from doing this kind of stuff is like telling
your job you want to leave for like two months to go somewhere and like not being touched
is like kind of a hard no for almost every other job situation.
But I've been super lucky that like both like the flight program and the hospital there
are very supportive.
So they're like down to let me go.
Yeah that's cool.
Yeah that I find it very cool that you've been able to kind of create your your world
in that sense right being able to have that flexibility that you want.
And then do these kind of extreme and awesome things.
Thanks so yeah.
Appreciate that.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I had some other questions and I totally forgot them.
That's totally fine.
Well if we think of them we can do this again sometime.
Yeah this was really cool.
Yeah thanks for sharing your thoughts and stuff.
For sure.
Thanks for coming on.
I always enjoy learning stuff from you so.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick before we get going just a couple of shout outs.
First is to the St. Fisher Church of Evidence Based Medicine.
If you haven't seen their page definitely go check it out.
We used to also give a shout out to the Pragmatic Paramedics.
I don't think they're active anymore but definitely take a look at their back episodes.
It's a good podcast.
And then lastly shout out to my friend Josh Pittman and his friend Kevin Pons.
They're the ones who put the music together.